y
[Música]
el actual primer ministro de portugal
antonio acosta podría ser reelegido los
resultados preliminares le dan a su
partido socialista la victoria parcial
en las legislativas hoy por detrás se
encuentran el principal opositor partido
social-demócrata seguido del
ultraderechista llega
eeuu y reino unido- planean ampliar el
alcance de las sanciones contra rusia en
un intento por disuadir la atención con
ucrania mientras que la otan descartó
que tenga previsto desplegar tropas de
combate en territorio ucraniano porque
el país no es miembro de la alianza
el presidente de israel llegó a emiratos
árabes unidos- en la primera visita
oficial de un jefe de estado de este
país el evento es la más reciente señal
de profundización de los lazos entre
ambas naciones que normalizaron sus
relaciones en 2020 con mediación de eeuu
bienvenidos de nuevo a las noticias de
france 24 mi nombre es maría clara calle
y los acompañaré en este recorrido y
comenzamos en portugal el partido
socialista del primer ministro antónio
costa se proyecta como el ganador de las
elecciones legislativas los resultados
preliminares publicados por el medio
estatal rtp muestran que esta
colectividad obtendría cerca del 42 por
ciento de los votos muy por encima del
28 por ciento del principal opositor el
partido socialdemócrata mientras que la
extrema derecha de sega sacaría 7% de
confirmarse el resultado contra diría de
las encuestas que marcaban un empate
entre costa y el líder de la oposición
ruiz río
eeuu planea aumentar la presión en el
consejo de seguridad contra rusia en la
reunión que se desarrollará el lunes
mientras que reino unido planea aprobar
una nueva legislación que permitirá
darle un mayor alcance a las posibles
sanciones
la idea es disuadir al kremlin para que
no ataque a ucrania y aunque la otan
dijo que no tiene previsto desplegar
tropas de combate en este país cientos
de voluntarios se entrenan en kiev para
recibir formación militar rafael pérez
con los detalles
no entres en pánico prepárate ese es el
lema con el que grupos militares
entrenan los voluntarios y veteranos
ucranianos dispuestos a defender el país
ante una posible invasión rusa no se
supone que todo el mundo sepa disparar
correr ser un profesional pero por
desgracia en la realidad actual esto es
lo que nos dictan las circunstancias
saber al menos un nivel elemental de
cómo comportarse durante un bombardeo
o le pertenece al batallón de azov un
grupo de voluntarios de extrema derecha
que en su momento luchó contra los
separatistas de danielle actualmente el
destacamento se encuentra bajo la
supervisión del ministerio del interior
ucraniano sin embargo los altos mandos
del batallón creen que las respuestas
del gobierno son ineficaces para
enfrentar la amenaza de invasión
hoy en día estamos hablando del plan
preparado por la federación rusa para el
nuevo ataque contra territorios
ucranianos y al mismo tiempo estamos
hablando de la absoluta ineficiencia de
las acciones del gobierno y es por eso
que tomamos esta misión por nuestras
manos y comenzamos a entrenar a la
población civil los entrenamientos
consisten en instrucciones que van desde
como sostener un arma hasta maniobras
más complejas los alumnos son personas
de diversas edades y profesiones quiero
escuchar y ver para entender los
acontecimientos y obtener información de
primera mano para saber qué hacer en
caso de ataque en otro sitio de kiev la
capital ucraniana cientos de personas se
reunieron para agradecer el apoyo de
occidente en medio de las tensiones con
moscú
la multitud portaba pancartas elogiando
la otan banderas estadounidenses y de
otros miembros de la alianza
trasatlántica esto sucede mientras rusia
acumula unos 100.000 efectivos en la
frontera con ucrania
y vamos a irlanda del norte que hoy
conmemora el aniversario número 50 del
llamada bloody sunday o domingo
sangriento
y es que el 30 de enero de 1972 soldados
británicos mataron a 13 católicos
desarmados que marchaban a favor de los
derechos civiles en el homenaje de hoy
familiares de las víctimas marcharon en
la ciudad de londonderry portando flores
y fotografías de sus seres queridos el
único militar que fue acusado
y enfrentó un juicio
esta semana del parlamento de cataluña
en españa aprobó una resolución para
reparar la memoria de cientos de mujeres
que fueron ejecutadas hace cientos de
años supuestamente por ser brujas para
los parlamentarios realmente se trataron
de feminicidios la manera de reparación
le pidieron a los ayuntamientos que
incluyan sus nombres en la nomenclatura
de las calles para hablar de esto vamos
hasta barcelona donde está susana
segovia ella es diputada por la
coalición cataluña han como puden señora
segovia bienvenida a france 24 ante el
parlamento la diputada aurora magdala
afirmó que la reparación puede y tiene
que ser un referente para la defensa de
los derechos de las mujeres usted está
de acuerdo con esta afirmación y cree o
no que sea así
claro lo que hicimos nosotros justamente
esta semana en el parlament de catalunya
en realidad es reconocer
institucionalmente una campaña que ya
hace años que hay en cataluña que ha
tenido mucho apoyo social que justamente
lo que pide es reparar a estas mujeres
que hace 300 400 500 años fueron
acusadas injustamente por ser bruja
fueron torturadas fueron asesinadas y
además fueron consideradas culpables por
toda una sociedad lo que hacemos ahora
en el siglo 21 es reconocer que en
realidad esto pueden feminicidio que se
las acusó por ser mujeres por ser
mujeres sabias' por ser mujeres
independientes por tener conocimientos
de cómo cuidar con plantas de cómo
cuidar la salud sexual y reproductiva de
las mujeres y ahora lo que hacemos es
dignificar su memoria a aprender de lo
que pasó y a partir de aquí ser capaces
de enfrentar estas acusaciones de estos
rumores que a veces nos llevan a muchas
mujeres a estar como en exposición
pública
y evidentemente salvando las distancias
pero sí que creemos que es necesario
recuperar esa memoria estudiarla y saber
que esto es un hecho que pasó en la
historia europa y en el debate
parlamentario varias colectividades como
box y el pp se opusieron a la medida
asegurando que era irrelevante reparar a
estas mujeres que le respondería usted a
estos partidos
cuando box de una fuerza ultraderecha y
el partido popular nunca tenían sus
prioridades los derechos de las mujeres
tampoco la recuperación de la memoria
histórica también cuando intentamos
reivindicar todas las personas que
fueron asesinadas y torturadas durante
la guerra civil durante el franquismo
ellos creen que no es importante y esto
ahora no toca nosotros creemos que sí
que toca que la recuperación la
reparación de las víctimas de un
feminicidio que afectó a centenares de
mujeres merecen ser tenidas en cuenta
que esto no es incompatible con hablar
de los otros problemas que pasan en la
ciudadanía por suerte los parlamentarios
tenemos la capacidad de hablar de muchos
temas sin que uno sea menor o mayor que
otro y sí que creemos que es necesario
por ejemplo que los estudiantes pues mi
hija que está en sexto de primaria sepa
lo que pasó en esta xxiv a cuando
estudia la edad media estudia los
derechos de los de los campesinos de los
nobles de la iglesia pero no lo que pasó
con las brujas muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 y por este
análisis en otras noticias el presidente
de israel isaac herzog llegó este
domingo a emiratos árabes unidos- en la
primera visita oficial de un jefe de
estado israelí a ese país el mandatario
fue recibido por el ministro relaciones
exteriores y luego se reunió con altos
funcionarios entre ellos el líder de
facto emiratí el príncipe heredero de
abu dhabi este viaje es la más reciente
señal de profundización de los lazos
entre ambas naciones que normalizaron
sus relaciones diplomáticas en el 2020
con la mediación de eeuu
es un momento muy conmovedor para mí
para mi pueblo el pueblo de israel que
está muy emocionado de continuar y
desarrollar la coexistencia pacífica y
nuestro acuerdo de paz entre nuestras
dos naciones los emiratíes y los
israelíes
su visita señor presidente se produce
poco tiempo después de la visita del
primer ministro israelí a los emiratos
árabes unidos esta es una prueba de que
nuestra relación avanza continuamente y
existe una fuerte voluntad común de
mejorarla por el bien tanto de nuestros
países como de nuestros pueblos
y de medio oriente nos vamos a áfrica
porque al menos una persona murió en
jartúm la capital de sudán cuando las
fuerzas de seguridad dispararon contra
los participantes de una nueva marcha
que rechaza el golpe de estado que
ocurrió el pasado 25 de octubre del 2021
ya serían en total 79 civiles muertos
desde que inició el golpe todo esto
según las cifras de un organismo de
médicos independientes en sudán los
uniformados lanzaron además gases
lacrimógenos para dispersar a los
manifestantes
ellos salieron a las calles de la
capital y también marcharon por otras
ciudades del país desafiando la
prohibición de movilizaciones
y para terminar un concierto con el que
el afgano homayun aquí quiere recrear la
cultura de su país desde londres este
músico el más popular tocando rumba del
mundo dice que así siente a su país en
sus manos el dinero que recauda en todos
sus conciertos es para enviarlo a su
país natal allí la ley islámica prohíbe
escuchar música que no sea religiosa
aquí se lamenta que ahora en territorio
afgano no haya música y hace todo para
revivir la estando por fuera de
afganistán
[Música]
y con esta música del rugby nos
despedimos por ahora pero ustedes sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24 y
consulten nuestra página web france24
puntocom nos vemos en minutos
[Música]